[موسيقى]
فصول السنه شتاء وربيع وصيف وخريف لا تبدا
بشكل فجائي بل بتمرحل زحزاح وهذا تمرحل له
امارات سماويه وعلامات زراعيه وحشريه
فاصفرار اوراق الاشجار دليل على بدايه
البرد واختفاء الحشرات والزواحف دليل على
شده البرد وظهورها مجددا دليل على نهايه
البرد والعرب ليس لديهم تقاويم خاصه
يعرفون بها دخول وخروج المواسم كحال
ايامنا هذه بل يعرفون ويعتمدون على ما
يشاهدونه من نجوم السماء وما يحسونه
ويتحسسونه من اشياء نحن الثريا وجوزاؤها
ونحن ذراعان والملزمه وانتم كواكب منحوسه
ترى في السماء ولا
تعلمي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام سنلاحظ توريق الاشجار
وتطليع النخيل وخروج الزواحف والحشرات
وهذا دليل وعلامه على اننا بدانا نقترب من
الاجواء المعتدله ونعومتها والاجواء
المعتدله والجميله تمر بنا بسرعه الله يا
سرعه الليالي والايام راحت تنتم من عمرنا
ما درينا قبل امس اذكر تونا باول العام
واليوم بالعام الجديد ابتدينا
[موسيقى]